our next story is about Haiti the
poorest country in the Western
Hemisphere a base for dozens of armed
gangs who even forced their prime
minister to resign Haiti always seems to
be in a state of chaos it's been that
way since it became independent back in
18004 but maybe that's not the country's
fault completely a group of NOS has
gathered in Geneva they're trying to
form an independent commission to help
undo a historic Justice they want France
to pay a ransom that it took from Haiti
back in the 1800s the price it extracted
for hai's
Freedom how much money does the
Coalition want France to
pay anywhere between 150 to $200 billion
here's our
report have you heard of the term War
reparations it's a specific type of
payment given by a losing country to the
winner of a war this has always taken
place in
history Germany paid this to the
Victorious allies after World War II and
after World War I as well France paid
this to Britain after Napoleon Was
Defeated War reparations are a way for
the losing sight to pay for the lives
lost this is how it has always been the
business side of War but what if the
roles were reversed if the winner of a
war had to pay the loser even if the war
was justified if it was the morally
right thing to do we don't have to
imagine that scenario it's what happened
to Haiti and the country has been
suffering for 200 years because of this
Haiti is the poorest country in the
Western Hemisphere it's a country in the
Caribbean Sea it occupies half of an
island Hispanola the other half is a
different country the Dominican Republic
where the people are on average 10 times
richer than the Haitians what led to
this stock disparity simply put France
was once a French colony called sand
doing France filled it with sugar and
coffee plantations and slaves to work on
them by the year 1789 90% of the people
in San doming were slaves subjected to
barbaric cruelty by the French
colonizers so the slaves rose up to
break their shackles they finally won
their freedom from the French in 1804
after fighting for over a decade the
people even defeated Napoleon's M making
a place for themselves in history but
the joy was shortlived Napoleon was
beaten in Europe as well the French
monarchy was restored and they wanted
their colony back France sent another
Armada in
1825 500 cannons were pointed at the now
free nation of Haiti and the French made
them an offer at gunship Point pay 15
million Franks for your freedom or we'll
enslave and kill you again let's look at
a cont temporary comparison the
Louisiana Purchase the US actually
purchased much of the present day South
and Midwest from France back in the year
1804 more than 2 million square km of
land about 77 times the size of Haiti
how much did the US pay France 80
million Franks or $15 million 21 years
later France forced Haiti to pay almost
double this amount 150 million Franks
now obviously Haiti did not have that
kind of money so France made it borrow
the money from French Bankers there were
Banker fees and interest which meant
Haiti was paying off the ransom for
122 years the final payment was made in
1947 that is when Haiti was free of the
French debt so how much do you think the
total debt was worth well that is a
question that will be debated by a
United Nations group the UN permanent
Forum on people of African sent 20 NGS
have come together they're asking the
forum for justice they want France to
return what it took from Haiti when you
add interest it may be between 150 to
$200
billion France will deny this of course
they have only ever acknowledged a moral
debt that they owe Haiti never actual
compensation Haiti is the poorest of its
neighbors brimming with gang violence
and a history of impoverishment the
French robbery play played a huge part
in this mess and this time ptis should
be the one paying